hallo leute was soll ich sagen es ist
wieder ein wunderbarer tag die sonne
scheint mir auf mein haupt ich bin
gesund ich bin fröhlich die
waschmaschine läuft im hintergrund warte
ich mal in die tür zu und ja ich muss
sagen ich war als mega dass euch die
hilf mir wirklich gut gefallen das video
vor zwei tagen ist auch schon auf über
hunderttausende aufruf hat schon fast
10.000 likes unter dem letzten video
direkt auf einen typen der seine
freundin messen will habe ich mega viele
kommentare bekommen und mir erfolgt
unter anderem der luigi reagiere auf
mein sohn 35 glaubt er wäre ein
sechsjähriges mädchen okay geht machen
wir ja auch schon das video 1,7
millionen aufrufe kann ich auch
verstehen weil der titel klingt echt
geil aber ich glaube werden heute
bisschen spaß haben wir ein leute wir
haben ein ganz normales mädchen zimmer
ist schön eingerichtet wir haben tiere
an der wand ja was soll man sagen
einfach ein typisches kinderzimmer für
ein junges mädchen oder mich zeit
aufzustehen
[Musik]
was soll der scheiß was älter seine
mutter nein nein man muss wirklich ganz
objektiv und neutral sagen wirklich mit
dem mädchen was eine operation wollte
und verglichen mit dem jungen der seine
freundin gemessen hat ist das hier
einfach noch mal das ist ein anderes
level das ist fast ein horrorfilm
wo kann man gerade diese stimmen sprung
her
ja natürlich ich weiß was das jahr 2018
und jeder kann frei mit seinem körper
umgehen und damit machen was er will
aber ich muss trotzdem sagen die
prinzessin die ich kenne haben ein
bisschen weniger beim k k cup manchmal
ohne wird wissen was ich will man die
redakteure von hilfen wir sprechen ich
will die menschen sprechen und
interviewen die sich diese geisteskranke
ausdenken nicht davon wenn 85-jährige
mann haben der denker sein sechsjähriges
mädchen und dann rennt da jemand über
die straße und politik beide perfekt das
nehmen wir auch in 2000 folgte das mit
dem hersteller bis nicht verstanden
alles klappt perfekt heute wir haben uns
eindeutig verstanden dieser stelle der
hashtag den ich es auch an dieser stelle
in die kommentare schreiben würde ist
natürlich hashtag
darüber hinaus leute ich weiß nicht wie
es bei euch ist aber wenn ihr auch 1000
fällen sogar ein paar tagen wollte würde
ich unter diesem video man auch mal ganz
schnell mit hashtags krippe so viel
kommentieren rüdiger hat sich in eine
traumwelt geflüchtet und bildet sich ein
er wäre ein sechsjähriges mädchen ohne
willst das ist ja sowieso die auch die
stelle wo ich am meisten ab kacke welt
einfach so diese absurde scheiße die
sich irgendein mensch auf einem ganz
ganz harten droht trick ausgedacht hat
wenn noch von irgendwelchen experten
kommentiert wird und die so tun als wenn
das gerade wirklich passiert und es
werden menschen mit echten problemen an
dieser stelle schon mein ur ur ur ur ur
großvater im jahr 1750 die damals auf
dem gebiet des heutigen deutschland saß
und sich gefragt hat wie wird die welt
im jahr 2000 aussehen wenn menschen
fliegen können wenn sie ewig leben
es tut mir leid wenn wir nur das sind
doch folgt wahrscheinlich pop doch noch
zusammen ja wie soll ich das sagen leute
wenn ihr auch in eurem bekanntenkreis
menschen hat der 35 jahre alt ist ein
mann ist und sie als prinzessin
verkleidet dann würde ich mir an dem
punkt auch schon sorgen machen aber aber
was jetzt ganz gefährlich ist leute ist
welche mit diesem 35 jahre alten
männlichen sechsjährigen mädchen auf den
spielplatz geht und diese person euch
dann fragt ob sie mit den anderen
kindern spielen darf das macht
vielleicht mich
das ist nicht mein nachher nicht gut
[Musik]
das kennst du das mal so da denkt ist
hier nicht so muss los oder das war der
vater hat angst um sein so das löst ihr
neben aggressionen aus die sich gegen
rüdiger richter und die beschreibung
sind auch nicht der oberhammer
ob diese braunhaarige frau das auch so
macht wenn er alleine zu hause ist ich
sitze auf einer grauen sitzgelegenheit
mit stoffbezug ich bin aufgestanden
was ihr kassen ppm musik doch gar nicht
einfach das spiel hier alle anderen
kinder ja auch leute was auch mal sagen
ich habe mittlerweile auch aufgegeben
bei jeder schwer irritiert szene aus
nahm zimmer auszurechnen weil ich weiß
am ende komme ich jetzt auch wieder
hierher und muss mit dem rest dann
trotzdem anschauen ganz ehrlich gesagt
youtuber sein während einfacher job
er musste noch nie am ende eines solchen
video ist eine verabschiedung machen
muss